one of the things we've been trying to
understand in this cost of living crisis
is just how much different energy costs
because you know primarily it's natural
gas that's gone up a lot in price and so
has electricity how that kind of feeds
down the chain and what we've done is to
try to start the very start of the chain
[Music]
now you ever wondered where salt comes
from table salt well the answer is
actually 400 meters beneath our feet
here in picturesque cheshire
there is a very big slab of salt down in
the ground and under here there is
what's called a solution mine how does
it work well basically compressed air
goes through that pipe and then you've
got water pumped in through that pipe
that goes down into this enormous cavern
that's basically got water going through
it so you're mining rather than mining
with pickaxes you're mining with water
and then out of this pipe comes
have a look at this
that is brine
so that is very salty water that's
coming directly out of the ground
this is incredibly salty actually
and that's kind of the beginning of a
process
that
tells you a few things it tells you
about how industry works around this
country because that is the start of so
many different supply chains whether
it's in pharmaceuticals whether it's in
food whether there's all sorts of other
things as well
but also
it's an energy intensive process this
gets piped off around the countryside it
gets turned in salt gets turned into
other products but a lot of gas is spent
along the way trying to process it
and understanding that supply chain
understanding how we get this seemingly
simple material
tells you quite a lot about this cost of
living crisis we're going through right
now
[Music]
we are at the nippon electric class
factory just outside wigan
and
i'm willing to bet that you might not
have thought all that much about
fiberglass i haven't really but right
now having just been through this
process and seen how it's made i can
tell you it's one of the most
extraordinary things ever
uh we'll get to what it's for in a
moment but basically it's for a lot of
important things
what's striking about this and we've
watched as it's gone through a furnace
you've seen sand and other ingredients
melted down at a
5 600 degrees see them turned into
basically kind of molten glass we've
seen them threaded into tiny
tiny strands thinner than a human hair
and then wound up again
and a few things have left out first of
all
this is an incredibly energy intensive
process
this place does it pretty much better
than most other places in the world but
it takes a lot of energy it takes a lot
of natural gas it takes a lot of
electricity to power the furnaces and
then you've got these kind of big
drawing uh equipment over here where
it's getting blasted with hot air well
that's
both drying it but at the same time it's
curing it so it has a kind of double uh
function
and there is no simple way of just
replacing one of these different
things they do and energy sources with
electricity and i think that's one of
the important things we're starting to
learn here is as we try and work out how
to become less reliant on natural gas
specifically maybe in this case russian
natural gas
there are so many different processes in
how we get the stuff we need which need
natural gas at least right now we have
no proven way of replacing them with
electricity for the time being at least
but the end product is this this is
fiberglass and you can see it's just
so essentially strands and it's in coils
here but what is that for that is going
to become part of the wind turbines that
are going to generate the new green
electricity we're going to have in the
future and in order to get that you need
natural gas and therein lies the big
paradox that we're facing at the moment
we need these fossil fuels to build the
stuff
to help us escape
from the fossil fuels
this is valley growing nurseries we're
just outside of london and this is an
enormous greenhouse devoted to well
growing tomatoes and if you want to grow
this stuff here
in the uk there's a whole load of
different costs so energy you need to
try and keep this greenhouse at a kind
of regular temperature just over 20 20
21 degrees and as well as that you need
to have it kind of stocked with extra
carbon dioxide one of the clever things
they do here is they've got a natural
gas boiler that's kind of doing the
heating and those bars on the on the
floor there are providing the heating
but as well as providing heating the
natural gas boiler also has excess co2
the stuff that goes normally into the
atmosphere well that's pumped into here
and then
aids photosynthesis so tomatoes in
particular they like a lot of co2 so in
here
the parts per million of co2 is actually
kind of two three times what it is in
the atmosphere
outside you put all of that together and
you're talking about a lot of energy
costs that need to go into production
and that's not the only thing you've
also got fertilizer costs they've gone
up by multiples as well why because
fertilizer is made in part from natural
gas and it's a very energy intensive
process as well
put all of that together and it helps
explain why costs here are up by 40 or
so maybe even more
and helps explain why food prices in the
coming
months could well get even more
expensive than they are at the moment
that's a bit of an issue given we're all
facing a cost of living crisis and given
that food costs
are one of the things that affects
particularly those who are on lower
incomes even more than others all of
which is why we need to understand and
think about how we make the foods we eat
and what those higher energy costs are
doing to them